[Music]
two years ago we saw hollywood superstar
jason statham in the underwater horror
movie mech by jonas taylor
at the box office the film grossed a
respectable 530 million us dollars
as the hollywood reporter now reveals
wanna brothers is already working on a
sequel to the successful first part
rebecca director ben wheatley will
direct the second part of the film which
is based around the prehistoric shark
megalodon
it is also clear that the original
director john turtletop
will no longer be involved in the film
production although the sequel has only
been officially announced recently
mack was the most successful horror
movie of the year in 2018 which is why
the idea of a sequel
has been circulating behind the scenes
for quite some time
no matter if you liked the movie or not
at least it made horror movies about
animals acceptable again after the
sharknado franchise had moved the whole
thing
more into itself a running and trashy
direction for years
by the way fans of the first part can
once again look forward to the large
part of the original team
including screenwriters john and eric
hober who are back on board for the
latest ocean adventure
behind the scenes lorenzo de bonoventura
and bella avery are involved as
producers
an exact release date of mac 2 is
unfortunately not yet
[Music]
known
[Music]